sticking my pole in Colin Powell
sticking my pole in colden Powell hello
and welcome to gaben max is 100 seconds
as we round out the decade it's time to
take a look back at it it's been over 10
crazy years filled with news medicine
and inventions so let's take a trip down
memory lane how about it Gabe and I are
gonna have a bit of a race to see who
can remember more items and things from
the decade that was I can get Ken that's
why we're going to race we'll see so it
begins three President Barack Obama two
one go President Barack Obama the Iraq
war present jimick Afghan war present
your cash one George Bush to adult
friendfinder the tragic events dice
stock market stock bicycle laughs a real
estate bubble collapse bubble boom dice
games are there calm bubble collapse
laptop memory ever drinks man quick put
it on my cue right off draft put it on
my a scrap of paper DVR show your work
going success line check minus my dollar
a hardy bobbin on Carlton hurricane
Karina personal pan pizza magazine
spider-man 1 and 3 by demand to Bravo
network Rabbo network Carson Kressley
Carson Kressley let my ride with my ride
that movie with Sean Connery and
Catherine zeta-jones work Stratman she
goes under the literature like you're
trespassing in my castle which is like a
1.4 entrapment please turn us I wouldn't
FS I want my point